tempo on the queen getting the knight  into the game and knight g3 is a threat  as well  yes so i guess queen e3  i'm i'm feeling very cautious here  why not the good thing is that you can't  go rookie  chet because of rook f7 true but but  come can we just take and oh my god  queenie to knight g3 this is game over  oh that is it oh that's terrible oh my  god  that's terrible  okay it's been a long day it's been a  long day for everyone this  you know these things happen um let's  let's go back to to looking at this one  uh well i'm sorry sorry for duboff but  after this  yeah i think you can just be taken  actually  um because now again knight g3 isn't i  wonder if that was a  a mouse slip actually by dubois could be  there's queenie one might be better to  hold on to this pawn actually